sauf eric avant de parler de ton 10 de
cette année on va porter un toast à
celui de l'année dernière
trop de blabla ils commencent par boire
ils reconnaissent les gens dans la rue
maintenant à bord testard l'entente
quartier quand tu as à faire les courses
et au a en plus j'habite d'art baisse
alors c'est vraiment super tu t'es fait
de la tune un peu passablement ou la
table moi simplement que c'est pas trop
quoi bon ben c'est à dire je la place à
ses cafés vendus ont dû quand même fait
un succès médiatique
ah bon succès médiatique ce triomphe est
très bien pour moi les identitaires au
niveau de la vente propre l'en avant de
l'argent pas évidemment
c'est un film en séries télévisées et
brille avec car il sait bien c'est
marrant telle expérience pour moi
ouais et je me refaire un autre les là
un grand pied
romain goupil cependant pour le mois
prochain
et ça ça me plaît parce que c'est la
même chose mais
c'est autre chose comme effet quel rôle
d'un gorille est barbu et darbion
gorille parce que justement je suis dans
une petite clémentine jean petite
servante on sait pas d'où sort je sens
que j'arrive et j'étais eux je suis mali
d'un coup idiote dramatique quoi manger
un film alors il faut que c'est quoi un
c'est autre chose c'est très dur téchiné
je suis une [ __ ] halles qui se
prostituent pour se défoncer roland fait
toujours pas le cam on l'a toujours
points ça aurait de la fois que je t'ai
vu tu m'as dit je mettre plein de pognon
de côté pour le match paris se disent
peut-être tu vas y arriver c'est vrai je
vais y aller plus tard aux commandes
clients info qui n'a rien d'un coup tu
te sens comment ici ça va le nouveau 45
tours s'est combret c'est quoi l'amour
quoi je sentais ouais ça que ce sont les
petits refrains loin il chantait toutes
les voies mais c'est ainsi j'ai choisi
un réalisateur pour aller moi c'est
super qu'ils marquent à des visites
toutes les séances vidéo qui a fait des
arrangements qui a su comment ses fans
séparés pour la promo la tpr est un oui
je peux faire toutes les télés tous les
machins j'aimerais
ok c'est qu'on va poser beaucoup de
questions qu'ont tenté en ta promotion
oui je commence par toi tu ailles
allons-y
m
pour réussir dans le showbiz oui tu veux
réussir dans le showbiz blood bowl et au
cameroun par exemple dans château
château bon est-ce qu'il faut être super
messieurs zh super tueuse ou superman ou
deux super maquilleuse super magouilles
tu rentres chez toi un soir qu'est ce
qui ferait le plus peur de voir fabius
giscard sous la porte
fabius giscard simone veil ou david
agent
jusqu'à pourquoi parce que vraiment lui
dangereux
métro vicieux mboumoua dessus alors
j'aurais surtout faire qu'une boîte tous
médias mondiaux a envie d'avoir un
perroquet pas spécialement pensés comme
si c'était beaucoup de caisses aux prix
ils répètent 13e régiment à imagine que
tu as un perroquet quelle phrase tu
apprendras en première et a fermé le
gage ta pensée la capote ou coco arrête
là coco
cette affaire mais le gaz parce que j'ai
une cuisinière qui fuit en ce moment ça
serait très bien dit il va comment le
petit julien très bien très bien quel
âge il a 5 ans vous cinq ans et nous
salue tous
il commence à jouer de la gratte d'un
fabricant de mobiles ils jouent pas la
grameen djoudi il a aussi tâté là alors
ils s'enregistrent can't wait on imagine
que tu meurs c'est un jeu et l'orphelin
bah oui tu préférais qu'il soit confié à
qui la gênent masse à france gall ou à
vanessa paradis
walesa avant voici ta copine ouais
pourquoi pas jeanne mas à ce que cette
équipe
pourquoi je le déteste ce que je trouve
qu'elle est là quelque chose aux
phalanges à des tests pas un méchant je
trouve qu'elle est antipathique
ah bon à cause de la bête d'abord 52
tout quoi j'aime pas j'aime pas les
gentils c'est pas qu'ils prennent les
photos visage qui trouvent qu'elle veut
avoir l'air bof et qu'elle est pas par
exemple activement ses pas et c'est tout
à fait ça si tu pars sur une île déserte
oui oui quand même
tu partir avec un blanc un noir jaune ou
un rouge
et ben avec un blanc ce que les noirs
ali son traumatisme cuba avant celle qui
a continué cette histoire trop de blabla
il se fait des militants quant à lui
complètement
ouais les geôles alors qu'au foot
robinet voir senna singapour une ont
pris la tête et les blancs vraiment
c'est qu'ils sont sympas situe avec les
femmes les femmes noires et la fondation
attentionné massage à lutter contre ça
c'est quand qu'ils parlent et blanc
le plan c'était un jour tu vas au
cameroun comment tu vas faire alors
battre le mot d'amour le plus nul
maintenant mais qu'il ya un truc au lit
qui dit un des mots que je vais te citer
qui a aucune chance à l'école tout de
suite tu te dire c'est merci merci
encore encore
plus vite plus vite ou oui c'est ce qui
te plaît le mois à ce que ma chance avec
toi et marche est un mec qui dit merci à
toi et celui tu préfèrerais être au
concours encore l'examen en hausse et
c'est bien normal on est obligé de faire
le revolver couteau grenade t'obliger
oui ils préfèrent faire l'amour avec une
très jolie fille ou avec un maître et
les way avec un mec très bon bah oui
c'est parce que l'on est si je me sens
et il a essayé mais bon ça ne plaît pas
du tout pas du coup longtemps que tu
préfères un mec très laid oui non et ça
c'est sûr ça au moins c'est olivier
villa wayne imagine que tu sois violée
oui c'est les pierres question qu'on va
te faisais pendant toute la campagne
promotionnelle tendu un boisé pas facile
tu verras alors est ce que tu préfères
être violée par yannick noah harlem
désir ou isaac de bankolé
je dirais les 3 ha bon les divas
l'avouer un choix le spirent est quand
même
yannick parce que c'est un compatriote
défi avant je n'aurais pas de complexe
quoi tu vois père qu'il est mal au genou
ça fera pas plaisir harlem et à isaac
dans sa lettre en plus tendues comme
quoi l'amour
bon le vaisseau spatial 4 connais-tu la
jeunesse à 4 ans dans le vaisseau
spatial beaucoup je vous ai beaucoup à
la pesanteur
la liste est longue ppda a priori
prairies non pourquoi ce que la mobilité
n'est pas l'historique qui se passe là
il réagit pas quand ils vont d'abord
apprécié parce que ça ne le font pas pda
bruno masure à vie par ses liens avant
marronne un élu il a une chance même
chance sabatier sega micro vaut
maintenant
et encore ouais drucker ah oui j'adore
d'abord sa puissance est de rigueur
je pense qu'ils gardent la balle de
celui-ci à foucault dont le caire
drucker toujours bien sûr collard au
poker l'objet de la vitesse en dvd la
firme allemande diane kruger wade robes
sexy c'est bien intelligent alors il
nous ferait là combien ça se passe que
traverse et catherine lara poker comment